all right let's go to the phones and see
what is on people's minds at 6 1 7 8 3 0
47 50 starting today with our caller
from the tu-16 area code caller from
tu-16 what's your name where you calling
from today hi David I'm Connor I'm
calling from Cleveland hey Connor what's
up so I was listening to a facebook
livestream from heather cox richard
student a professor at Boston College
right she proposed something boy Connor
you're breaking up my friend she
proposed what you're breaking up
she proposed how did McConnell know that
Hillary wasn't going to win when he
blocked the nomination of Merrick
garland right but how did he know that
Hillary wasn't going to win this locker
that did he know something no I don't I
mean listen you it's a gamble right I
mean you might block it or you might not
if your guy gets in then trunk picks the
replacement it's not a guarantee I mean
I do is it is the idea that it implies
some kind of rigged election or
something like that that could be her
daughter oh okay I mean I haven't heard
what she said but if you I mean so if
you say you if you block this for a year
you might give the pick to a Republican
and if not listen you still delayed it
and okay Hillary gets to pick but you
you at least had a shot at it it doesn't
to me say that something conspiratorial
necessarily happened interesting so the
chances are that Biden would go ahead
and nominate Garland if he gets the
chance I have absolutely no idea I don't
know that merit god I mean that was
years ago I've no clue I've there's so
many people that could be chosen from I
don't I've not heard anything about
Biden and Merrick garland mmm all right
Connor thank you very much I appreciate
the call certainly something to think
about
let's go next to our caller from the
five-10 area code who's calling today
from five-10
uh hey hey David this is a rush from
California hey a rush what's up um yeah
so uh I kind of have a two-part question
okay
like firstly from from I like general
understanding when it comes to like
economic development in third-world
countries some of the like the main
contributing factors are like for growth
or like things like education the
infusion of foreign capital the
transference of like soft skills like
and foreign technology with that in mind
do you think that the policy that Paul
he's involving forced technology
transfer like that is the practice in
like which in which a domestic
government requires foreign businesses
to share their text class soft skills in
exchange from market access is that is
that a desirable thing for developing
countries with a large market right yeah
and if that in this is a second part now
if it is a good thing do you think that
the rise of multilateral critical trade
agreements which gives a stronger
protections against ftt through the
enforcement of intellectual property
rights and the ability to bring nations
to court investor state dispute
settlement there those those the ability
of those countries to engage in FTT the
answer to all of those questions is it
depends and it has to be looked at on a
case-by-case basis and it's that I'm not
to be clear I'm not picking on you here
when I say this arash but that's the
exact type of question where if you're
looking for a yes or no answer you're
essentially thinking about this the the
the wrong way because there is the
answers to those questions would depend
on what types of technologies are we
talking about which countries are we
talking about what are the underlying
industries and employment circumstances
of those companies of those countries
what currency is the prevailing reserve
currency in those countries and how does
that relate to the country in which the
businesses they're looking to buy opera
there's no possible way that I could say
yes that's good and know that it's not a
concern about the the arbitration it's
it's such a huge issue I don't see any
simple answer to it yeah yeah I guess I
was thinking it from the perspective of
like one of the arguments in favor of
for example tariffs right yeah the
infant in this infant industry argument
right so like could there be like like
specific sectors for example like a
high-skilled sectors like tell
occasions or like stuff like or like you
know biotechnology and stuff like that
in which you could help facilitate the
development of these specific industries
through the FTT you know but of course
of course that's certainly possible but
it's not guaranteed and that's why this
is the you you just have to deal with
really specific examples you know
multilateral trade deals Trump
increasingly is talking about bilateral
trade deals as opposed to multilateral
and a lot of his followers are just like
yeah Trump says it's good so that must
be good it must be good because the
Trump the big boy can negotiate directly
or whatever for me there's no hard and
fast rule about depending on which
countries we're talking about depending
on the scope of a particular trade deal
multilateral may be more logical or it
may not be if you when looking at the
supply chains for example if you are in
a country where your supply chain for
the areas that you're looking to do a
trade deal around are heavily dependent
on five other countries and you want to
do a bilateral trade deal with only one
of those countries that's a recipe ripe
for creating new problems so maybe a
multilateral deal is more appropriate
there in other cases where there is a
more direct competition and it's a more
an issue of specialization between two
countries maybe in that case it's the
bilateral trade deal that you need my
point is everybody claiming to have the
definitive answer on a lot of this stuff
is is not looking at specific examples
typically okay well uh it's good talking
you David nice calling in for the show I
appreciate the answer all right
appreciate the phone call Arash thank
you hope to hope to speak to you soon